et le Royaume-Uni tout comme les autres
pays sont donc très polarisés par
rapport au rôle de l'Europe il Frédéric
dans quelques jours ça risque de se
ressentir en tout cas pendant les
élections européennes voilà donc des
élections qui vont se tenir sur quatre
jours ça commence jeudi ça se termine
dimanche donc ça veut dire que les pays
membres ne votent pas tous en même temps
mais on va bien sûr attendre tout le
monde à la fin pour donner les résultats
donc quelques chiffres importants 28
États membres qui vont donc passer par
ce scrutin il y a 427 millions
d'électeurs qui vont se prononcer tout
ça pour y lire 751 euros députés alors
évidemment chaque pays a son propre
poids au niveau de la proportion donc ça
veut dire que si on regarde ce graphique
mais c'est évidemment l'Allemagne qui
aura le plus de d'euros députés avec 96
suivi de la France l'Italie au
Royaume-Uni et l'Espagne et ça va comme
ça et si jusque Luxembourg est mal qui
auront chacun 6 euros députés maintenant
ce qui est très particulier avec ces
élections là c'est qu'on ne vote pas
pour un candidat ou une candidate mais
bien pour une liste donc c'est à dire
qu'il y a des partis politiques qui
constituent une liste avec un nombre
suffisant de candidats et bien sûr parce
que c'est un scrutin à la
proportionnelle ce qui veut dire que
plus une liste a des votes plus
évidemment elle peut envoyer des
candidats et donc des députés à
l'Assemblée politique de Strasbourg une
fois que c'est candidats ont été élu
mais là il faut faire un choix parce que
dans l'hémicycle il y a 8 groupes qui
sont définis alors ça part évidemment
par exemple de l'extrême gauche là avec
par exemple la groupe la Gauche Unitaire
il y a les socialistes démocrates il y a
les Verts au centre il y a par exemple
les libéraux démocrates il y a le Parti
populaire européen et plus on va vers la
droite mais plus on a des parties qui
sont conservateurs qui sont
heureux-sceptiques et anti migration si
jamais les candidats ne se reconnaissent
pas dans ces groupes là et bien ils sont
alors des non inscrits il y en a
actuellement 22 et si on regarde à la
dissolution du Parlement la répartition
vous le voyez on va de l'extrême gauche
jusqu'à l'extrême droite c'est
actuellement le Parti populaire européen
qui a le plus grand nombre suivi des
socialistes et des démocrates et on
pourrait croire que c'est pas le cas
mais en fait elles sont importantes ces
élections parce qu'elles touchent
quotidien les électeurs effectivement
Céline parce que les 751 députés qui
vont au Parlement de Strasbourg mais ils
ont leur mot à dire d'abord ils votent
ils amendent ils discutent des lois qui
touchent par exemple
l'écologie l'environnement la santé ou
encore l'immigration donc c'est très
important pour les Européens or quand on
regarde il vote aussi le budget du de
l'Union européenne or quand on regarde
le taux de participation depuis la
première élection européenne
c'est-à-dire en 1979 mais regardez la
tendance est évidente on a un déclin
continu de 63% on est passé à 42 et il y
a rien qui laisse penser que c'est un
une tendance qui va s'inverser avec le
vote dans les prochains jours
merci pour ce petit cours sans un des
élections européennes très utiles merci
Frédéric